[Music]
well the 8 news now i-team recently told
you about the concern around lake las
vegas and the diminishing water levels
well the henderson community is in the
southeast part of the valley about 30
minutes it's about a 30-minute drive
from the strip well today both locals
and tourists are worried about the
future of the area especially the
village at lake las vegas where many
businesses are already struggling to
stay open
i think that lake is a part of what
draws families to come here we found
shamika bogan and rebecca bennett inside
this trendy eatery in lake las vegas a
cheek spot they say caught their eye on
social media it's beautiful it's
gorgeous it's everything that it looked
like online but actually being here in
the village and in the area we were
shocked at how
dead it was the village had only a
handful of businesses opened on tuesday
while a few beat the heat with the water
sports but it's a diminishing water
levels that many businesses refused to
talk to us about our 8 news now i-team
recently reporting lake las vegas is
currently not getting filled with
additional water after an intake pipe at
lake mead can no longer draw water
currently lake mead is at 1040 feet now
the pipe lake las vegas was receiving
water from reached 1050 feet this is a
beautiful place to come visit and if
there's a lake
what else
vegas has to offer raintree investment
corporation the company developing lake
las vegas which has hotels restaurants a
golf course and luxury homes tells 8
news now infrastructure has been put in
place for the lake to continue receiving
water from the city of henderson but the
paperwork needs to be finalized this
family tells us the area has been
struggling to attract visitors with only
a handful of activities and businesses
open
a grim reality these tourists hope can
change with social media promoting the
area for us it was a 30 minute commute
from the strip and so
it would have been nice to have more
things to come
other than just here
no
no it's beautiful
well the city of henderson and lake las
vegas are working on a long-term
solution according to a city
spokesperson you can find more on this
issue on our website 8newsnow.com